activist kimberly jones went viral when
she compared the economic inequality
black people face to the game of
monopoly
so if i played 400 rounds of monopoly
with you and i had to play and give you
every dime that i made and then for 50
years
every time that i played i if you didn't
like what i did you got to burn it like
they did in tulsa and like they did in
rosewood
how can you win
how can you win
her powerful speech was filmed in the
summer of 2020 during the protest across
the country after the death of george
floyd now kimberly jones is expanding on
her video in a new book it's called how
we can win race history and changing the
money game that's rigged in it she
explains the history and impact of
systemic racism in america and how we
can change it first on cbs mornings
kimberly jones joins us good morning
kimberly how are you doing i'm great
good morning so happy to be here with
you guys glad you're here now
in this viral video it connected with
millions of people why do you think that
is
um i think that people like information
concise and in a way that makes sense to
them easily and so i think it was
something in particular i got a lot of
messages from non-black people saying
this is something that i sent to my
grandmother to my mother to my aunt that
i fight with at thanksgiving and for the
first time things i've been telling her
she got it people also respond to anger
uh we have a natural inclination to to
pay attention when someone is angry and
you're open in the book about how that
was a moment of anger for you
yeah and it was righteous anger right
and so a lot of times you know people
think of like well if you're being angry
just calm down you don't need to do that
but i think sometimes in righteous anger
you get to express to people your pain
and i think that's what people saw even
though they saw an angry woman they saw
a hurt woman and so they felt that and
they were like oh my god the pain is
visible
you know i like what you said because in
your book you said people who saw you as
an angry black woman do not know you you
said the way you speak is cultural not
remedial
you were educated yet you were socially
unpolished i would disagree with that
about when you say that about yourself
and you said hood girls can be heroes
too yes what is the point that you're
making there kimberly the point that i'm
making is that's part of what's
happening when we look at what's
happening with police brutality it's
a bulldog perception um that that anger
that the way that you speak the way you
present yourself the community that you
come from gives less value to who you
are as a person and in particular with
colloquialisms and the way that black
people have grown etymology in this
nation and at the time in which people
are inventing it it's told that it's
less than but actually it has changed
the way we all speak if you say put your
hands together that comes from 1920s
jazz culture and so i wanted people to
understand that it's cultural and that
we are the architects of cool it's not
remedial and let's make the point too
that you were making that poverty
creates crime period yeah and people
can't understand that yes i tell people
i told policymakers that all the time
when i'm talking to them and they talk
to me about the crime especially like in
my city in atlanta and i'm like you're
not going to have a conversation with me
about crime until we have a conversation
about poverty
now you you in the end of the video you
said that you're lucky black people um
are looking for
equality and not revenge and then you
write that you wish you would have said
equity
yes why so i think primarily because
equity is where we are now and i think
we do a disservice to the people who
came before me the people like john
lewis and dr king and people like that
to say that progress hasn't been made
which is a universal thing that i hear
but i'm like they made extreme progress
in equality and what we're looking for
now is the change in equity and so a lot
of times a lot of the decisions the laws
the things that we're facing that are
that are crippling us are economic
decisions and so it's equity that can
push the envelope further now but people
go there they go again 400 years you're
bringing it up blah blah blah blah blah
that was then this is now and the point
you make is you have to know
the facts of the case before you can
make a before you can make a comment and
you have to truly understand what has
happened in this country exactly there's
no way to nurture empathy and people if
they don't know the full story i think
one of the greatest mistakes that we
have made we talk a lot about the
miseducation of the black child but it's
really the miseducation of the american
child that has allowed us to live in a
way that we don't have empathy for each
other because it's in that education
it's in that knowledge that you can
empathize with how a a person can come
the one thing i say all the time people
are like are you wanting to fight for
black excellence and i say no i want to
fight for black mediocrity the median
income in atlanta for black family is 17
000
the median income for a white family is
170 000
i want some of my people to be able to
be mediocre and still be able to provide
for their family this idea that you have
to be gayle king that you have to be
kimberly jones you have to be a
superstar to be successful is ridiculous
a person should be able to just be and
be able to take care of their family
gail brings up the right point a lot of
people say oh that was way back when all
these things you're talking about or
decades ago those people are not alive
but your point is that the legacy of
those actions still show up in our bank
accounts and our wallets they definitely
do and there's so much information that
people don't know about when you talk
about things like the freedmen's bank
which you know african americans lost to
the tune of 66 million dollars um in the
the bankruptcy of that bank that's
generational wealth when you talk about
redlining and the way black america was
not allowed to participate in home
ownership and then people say you want a
handout and i'm like well from 1920 to
1960 the u.s government underwrote 200
billion dollars in home lending and 98
went to white family listen i want
people to know this about you you were a
brilliant gifted child your mother was
told that when you started studying
shakespeare they change uh schools for
you you speak korean
so before you go could you say you're
watching cbs mornings with nate tony and
gail in korean
haseo kamida
kimberly jones you are the best we
appreciate it sound pretty polished to
me how we can win is on sale now we'll
be right back